près des caravanes de futurs t3 étaient
deux dans six mois
ces pavillons seront loués par des
membres de la communauté des gens du
voyage c'est vraiment une grande
satisfaction d'abord du point de vue des
factures aux habitants alors qu'ils
étaient déjà évidemment sur le site
publie dans des caravanes dans des
conditions très précaires
on parle d'assainissement on parle d'eau
absence aussi d'électricité alors
qu'avant il faut bien le reconnaître
certaines des constructions étaient dans
l'illégalité
kevin a toujours vécu ici aux abords de
la départementale 140 près de sa
caravane
la maisonnette de son père et le mobile
home de sa grande soeur à 22 ans kevin a
décidé de quitter le petit terrain
familial en juin prochain
il louera inde étaient trois ils
souhaitent se sédentariser et changer sa
vie au quotidien
la campus velma te faire ton ses choix
pas besoin de sortir dehors pour aller
prendre n'importe quoi du suc où il fait
bon on assume le crédit d'une caravane
sur 5 ans 10 ans donc on passe
maintenant peu à saint louis
est-ce qu'on habite un pavillon vous
ferai encore partie de la communauté des
gens ont fait tout le temps là quand on
fait partie d'autant la communauté de
gens du voyage même si on est sédentaire
depuis dix ans dix maisons et des
locataires éligibles à l'allocation
logement ce qui n'était pas le cas pour
la vie en caravane résultats kevin
devrait avoir un loyer mensuel de 150
euros au total l'aménagement du
lotissement piloté par val touraine
habitat avoisine les 1,5 million d'euros
dont un tiers provient des fonds
européens
une réponse particulière parce qu'on a
travaillé avec les familles donc ils ont
des besoins particuliers et le premier
de ses besoins
c'est l'installation de la caravane sur
le terrain dans lequel est édifié la
maison donc il a fallu réaliser les
maisons sur des parcelles suffisamment
grande pour que l'on puisse pour que
chaque famille puisse installer sa
propre caravane
parmi les 60 membres de la communauté
des gens du voyage deux familles n'ont
pas souhaité intégrer cette opération
immobilière inédite la ville de
montlouis sur loire devra les convaincre
de quitter un jour ou l'autre les
parcelles qu'elle occupe